c'est quand même à l'honneur de recevoir
le patron de la france au mondial s'il
veut manger avec why comme on dit aux
gars sera la goutte ensemble trois
éboueurs de paris ont pris ce matin un
petit déjeuner avec le président de la
république sur le coup de 6 heures et
demie monsieur giscard d'estaing
attendait les trois hommes dans la salle
à manger de l'elysée
vous saviez que le président allez vous
recevoir
non on ne se fait pas je ne savais pas
vous saviez pas que je briserai vous
recevoir non c'est nous c'est difficile
prise comme je sais qu'il aime les yeux
brouillés et c'est la spécialité de ma
femme parce que c'est bon je la
préférais c'est pas parce que le
président a rappelé qu'il a fait il
vient à notre table il vient à notre un
autre niveau il vient avec nous c'est un
homme comme les autres
pas n'importe lequel mais c'est un homme
comme les autres
nous avons sabler le champagne ensuite
mis à table tâche de cresson alors nous
avons commencé par est plat de jambon
refaire par le président nous avons
ensuite
du lapin avec des haricots verts
dujardin y avait un bar avec une
mousseline une côte de boeuf avec une
garniture de thomas qui restent sont
naturellement et de jardinière de
légumes bio un mont désert
il ya des fromages ensuite et la salle
alain bondue sûr je sais simplement une
charlotte
on voulait que ce soit très simple une
charlotte avec une crème anglaise parce
que le maître de leur destin
forcément dans son milieu ne connais pas
tous les ans des bois mm rayé peut avoir
et en parlant avec les français
directement alors vos impressions sur le
président et madame ce sont des
personnes très sain très très agréable
et avec qui la conversation est très
aisé avant dé connaître
est ce que vous les imaginez ainsi je
les imaginais assez simple dans
l'ensemble mais je je me suis aperçu que
c'était très facile d'être très simple
avec le teint soir la télévision on
avait eu entendu monsieur président qui
disaient qu'ils seraient très heureux
d'être reçus dans les familles
alors avec isabelle on s'est dit
pourquoi pas nous alors on a accueilli
mais sans dire un rappel moments et
monte pas au courant - est-ce que vous
avez parlé avec lui
oui j'ai parlé avec lui de quel problème
j'ai encore des problèmes de l'école
l'école
oui on a parlé absolument comme si on
était autour d'une table entre amis de
problème ou qu'on perde en train de vous
parler de tout et rien c'est ça on
aborder tous les problèmes sans les
approfondie en fait
bon alors au bout d'un moment c'est plus
devenu le président s'était québec oui
c'est ça c'était un ami vraiment que ce
qu'on pouvait parler de n'importe quoi
il s'intéressait à tout lors de quoi
avez vous parlé de tout ça enfin non des
problèmes sociaux
mon mari est descendu raccompagné
monsieur président et madame et lui a
dit qu'ils passaient certainement de
voir la qualité d'ailleurs il l'avait
déjà dit avant avant de venir ici mais
nous a pas dit venez dîner un soir à
l'elysée je ne pense pas non je ne pense
pas
[Musique]